-Welcome to our show.
-Yeah, this is crazy.
This is like, "Oh, my God.
It's Jimmy Fallon."
-No.
This is Matthias Schweighofer.
This is finally -- We meet.
-By the way, you say
"Schweighofer" like --
This is like really --
It's a hard word to say.
Like, your last name.
Even, you know...
-Shwegg...
-Hoffer. It's fantastic.
-Schweighofer. Yeah.
-Yeah, it's great.
-I have a little --
I'm half Irish, half German.
-Yes, and you --
-Yeah, yeah.
-So that's the Irish part of me
saying "Shwegg."
[ Laughter ]
My -- My grandmother
came over to America
at Ellis Island as a baby.
Schalla was her last name,
from Bremen.
-Okay, Bremen. Yeah.
-"Bremen."
-"Brayman." Yeah, Bremen.
It's like "Brayman."
-Of course.
-You say it's a --
-Of course. I know what
you're talking about.
I was doing a lot of research
on you because I was a fan
from "Army of the Dead,"
but then I saw this headline
and I loved it.
"Matthias Schweighofer:
They call me the Justin
Timberlake of Germany."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I feel --
I feel it a little bit.
But explain again why.
-I don't know.
If I -- if someone said that
in Germany or --
or if I said that
in an interview...
-[ Laughter ]
-Either way. It counts.
Someone said it, right?
-You know --
-This --
-Sorry. No.
No, really, it's because
there was a time, you know,
like, I'm -- I think
I'm a good dancer,
but a kind of shy dancer.
-What is shy dancing?
-Do you know like --
Shy dancer is, you know,
somewhere in the shades.
You really --
You think you're like --
Quest, can you give us a beat?
What would a shy --
-Like, when you, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like...
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-I like the kick at the end.
Why not a little pop
to the end there? Yeah.
I'm just so happy that you're
kind of exploding
here in America
and people are getting
to see how --
how charming you are,
but also how talented you are.
You directed this film,
as well as acting in it.
"Army of Thieves."
And here are some reviews.
Early reviews that came out.
Someone says, "In the early
scenes of his English language
directing debut, he occasionally
recalls Wes Anderson.
He even has echoes
of Martin Scorsese's
clockwork studies in 'Hugo.'"
-Isn't that cool?
-You just got compared
to Wes Anderson
and Martin Scorsese.
-I could be
Wes Matthias Scorsese.
-Wow. That is --
That is -- Yeah.
You should think about that.
So you're working
with Zack Snyder, right?
So that's a big break
right there.
But then you start doing --
you start doing the scenes,
and we had Tig Notaro
on the show,
and we were talking
about the movie.
And I watched the movie,
and I go --
She steals every scene.
I love her.
Then you come in.
I go, "Who is this guy?"
-Yeah.
-And you just stole every scene,
and you're just
charming and funny.
-Yeah, it was -- it was so --
You know, I was so happy
about the critics to be --
"You know, this German guy,
he's actually really funny.
He has a cool sense of humor."
And, you know,
because I always love --
You know, American comedy,
it's like, you know,
when I was younger --
Because I was born behind
the wall,
then the wall came down
in East Germany, so --
And then the world came down,
and, you know, everything
from America has swept over,
and I loved it.
-What were you watching?
What were you into?
-"Fresh Prince," you know?
And --
-Yeah, of course.
Of course, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-"Fresh Prince." Yeah.
-I loved it.
-It all begins
with "fresh Prince."
-I couldn't understand it
because I had no English.
But it was like this.
[ Singing theme song
in gibberish ]
You know, Will Smith's like...
[ Both singing in gibberish ]
-Yeah.
-And that was great.
And then I saw "E.T." for the
first time, and I thought --
"You know, the wall came down.
And in America, it's possible
to talk to aliens."
[ Laughter ]
-Anything is possible.
Anything is possible
in America, yes.
-And I loved it.
And so I started to dream big,
and here we are.
-Ah. Well, I'm so excited.
I'm happy that you're here.
I'm happy that we're --
-Thank you.
-We meet each other
and we're friends now.
-Yeah, we're friends. Yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Matthias Schweighofer
in "Army of Thieves."
Take a look of this.
-I just want to clarify
once more.
-Zip it!
-Okay.
Okay. If you say so.
[ Beeping ]
♪♪
[ Clicking ]
[ Thud ]
♪♪
[ Clicking ]
-Ladies and gentlemen!
There's a new kid in town!
-That's right!
There's a new kid in town.
Matthias Schweighofer!
"Army of Thieves" begins
steaming on Netflix tomorrow.
Hello to all our friends
in Germany.
Thank you so much for watching.